what's up guys Oscar nominations came
out today it's a pretty cool list snubs
surprises what's going on we have a
star-studded panel to talk about it with
us first he is the star of being human
Mondays 9:00 p.m. on the sci-fi channel
Sam Huntington eh yeah yeah we're doing
it he is the star of the upcoming movie
cheap thrills draft day and Captain
America Winter Soldier mr. Pat Healy hey
it's Mel Sam's head yeah it's good
though yeah so the list is out is there
anything here where you're like what the
hell were they thinking I'm just really
surprised that Tom Hanks is not
nominated for both the films that he
started in this year saving mr. banks
but particularly Captain Phillips
Christian Bale who I think is terrific
in American hustle great wig work taking
his [ __ ] his slot he took his slide took
his slug service out yeah so Christian
Bale took Tom axe it appears to be so I
think all of these are and I like the
late surge of wolf of wallstreet it came
in late it wasn't how many for SAG
Awards but it got nominated in all of
the categories it should have except for
editing Sam was there anything that you
were like really happy to see on the
list yeah I was really happy to see
Dallas buyers club on there and I'm also
that very happy that Jared Leto is uh is
nominated cuz I thought he was fantastic
and absolutely I was like completely
captivated by him also happy
McConaughey's on those yeah what do you
guys think of it it seems like Matthew
McConaughey is like taking a sharp turn
into becoming like a great actor that
she's awesome using yeah uh it seems to
me like I call it the reverse Nic Cage
which is like Nic Cage like played all
these weirdo parts and then like once he
got nominee for an Oscar became the
leading man sure and McConaughey was
kind of started off as a weirdo yeah now
he's like finally discovered that no I'm
good at this at being sort of these
offbeat characters I would really in Sam
is there anything not present that you
thought should have been nominee yeah I
really enjoyed and I actually was mixed
on the film but I really enjoyed Emma
Thompson and saving mr. banks I thought
it was uh I thought she was a that was a
beautiful performance I was missing a
little bit of her motivation throughout
yeah that's not her fault I thought it
was a really very natural performance
and I really
really bought it all the way through one
of the most fun films of the year
Pacific Rim not nominated for visual
effects
yeah the hata haven't had those barrels
so yeah it's true
I'm embarrassed set in the sea the Lone
Ranger uh I haven't seen it I haven't
seen it either so why are you
embarrassed
well I am I am Barret I don't know just
cuz it's on this list and I haven't seen
it most people say they're embarrassed
that they have say I've seen it I'm
embarrassed that I buzzing The Lone
Ranger cuz I'm having lunch with Arnie
hammer lady later today
you are you mean army army army ham
don't call Arnie I want to get into
acting categories and we have two
excellent actors here to talk about yeah
you really do best actor Christian Bale
Bruce turned DiCaprio shotel Ejiofor
mm-hmm and methan khan a so it's very
rare for a fur to time for them to get
this right Robert Redford a lot of
people are saying he might have gotten
it for all his lost cuz he's never won
and he's been a he's only ever been
nominated once for the thing I think
it's interesting that Jonah Hill getting
his second nomination and he has more
acting nominations in Robert Redford
Jonah Hill has been nominated twice now
it's interesting but Jonah Hill is
absolutely brilliant in in this movie
fun to watch she's been nominated more
than Gary Oldman that's classy that's
that's amazing yeah old it's only been
nominate one once for last year for
Tinker Tailor yes years ago yeah moly we
were talking about Jonah Hill Supporting
Actor anything that were surprised by or
I mean III had thought that barkhad Abdi
from Captain Phillips will be nominated
it's surprising that he's nominated Tom
Hanks is not yes a little a little
strange but good for him I don't know I
am a huge fan of Bradley Cooper in this
film American hustle I think he's great
as an actor what would be tougher
gaining the weight that Christian Bale
did or getting the perm like Bradley
Cooper did I think it's really
interesting that if you lose or gain
weight in a movie I know you get you get
an Oscar in addition which I like these
performances by let's say Matthew
McConaughey lost weight or Christian
Bale to gain weight oh it's one thing to
lose weight it's another thing to bring
the performance I think that both of
those guys really really nailed it Best
Actress I was blown away by Cate
Blanchett old blue Jasmine she's great
and I felt the way about Meryl Streep as
I always feel about her she's
brilliant what when is she gonna be bad
is it everything it's never gonna happen
in fact she's getting better and she's
becoming a more popular actress box
office you don't know it's incorrect
there has been some criticism about
Meryl Streep that she just choose the
scenery so what I don't I don't
understand when we got to this point
where acting is everything radiation
yeah yeah it's all time I think that
there's I'm a mumblecore guy
are you alright if it's good it's good I
just think we're obsessed now with with
realism and I think it has to do with
reality TV but if if it were an empty
scenery-chewing performance yeah say
that but there's such a great core of
emotion in this character especially get
in her smaller moments in the film which
are tremendous it's a real talent to be
able to pull off that kind of subdued
performance and make it believable
I support scenery-chewing I support Al
Pacino scenery-chewing
alright if you want to take the
controversial view that Meryl Streep is
a good actress have that okay take it
Best Supporting Actress
I think Julia Roberts is a bit of a
surprise yeah I think she's due for
something like that you know like I feel
like it's been a long time for her what
I like about her performance in the
movie is it is very non vain she doesn't
wear any makeup you know that's cool she
appears to show the way she she really
looks in real life and she's going up
against Meryl Streep which is no easy
fast for any actress even hers look at a
Best Picture year I think
well the biggest omission maybe inside
Llewyn Davis haha
that's my biggest thing I mean I wasn't
surprised to hear about that because it
had been ignored by all the Guild's of
directors guild producers guild the
Writers Guild didn't nominate that I
think it's their best film probably
since The Big Lebowski or Fargo I loved
the film but that's a lot of people do
not like it we've talked about the
categories individually let's go down
and I want you to tell me who you think
is going to win all right let's start
with Best Picture 12 years of slave will
probably win the Best Picture Sam I was
thinking - a woeful wolf of wallstreet
I would love to see wolf of wallstreet
when I think it's just to calm down that
would be my preference but I don't think
they know that it would be too
controversial and I think it would also
be very controversial to not give it to
12 years of slavery yeah I think fair
enough I think 12 years of slave is
gonna get it yeah Best Director yeah I
think that 12 years of slavery win best
picture but I think Alfonso Cuaron will
win the Best Director I just think
that's such a director's film and he
wasn't recognized for children of me
yeah which I thought was such a
brilliantly directed film Best Actor
who's gonna win I would say probably
Chiba tell Ejiofor matthew mcconaughey
it's a toss-up with the possible Bruce
Dern upset sad I hope it's Matthew
McConaughey I loved his performance so
much I thought he was fantastic um I'd
say McConaughey it was awesome okay
Supporting Actor uh there's been a lot
of talk of Michael Fassbender but I
think this is Jared Leto's category he's
won almost every major award every major
critics award and did you like I was
gonna say deserve it too like I thought
that performance and its mystique II I
didn't I didn't expect it Best Actress
that's a tough one it seems to be Cate
Blanchett seems to be the favorite but I
wouldn't be surprised if any Adams took
it just because she's been nominated
that would be criminal man that would be
ah I think Amy Adams from Cate Blanchett
was she's she's gonna win though right
she's gonna win her portrait of like the
mentally unstable woman I'm not mad at
you Pat I'm mad at the seems like you
are I like hats the embodiment of the
poor God just goes in the middle I don't
want his terrible the messenger Kate
planche I think you're probably gonna be
right yeah I think you're probably right
and Best Supporting Actress I love
Jennifer Lawrence I would give it to her
I think she has a good chance of winning
it seems like Jennifer Lawrence can do
no wrong lately and yeah I I think she's
amazing I'm kind of obsessed with her
and I love her I love her off screen
persona to cool down to earth now before
we wrap it up a wish list is there
anyone that you think or any movie that
you think this would never get nominated
but hey how about it I'll start it off
okay um Tom Hiddleston is Loki the guy
stole every damn scene he was in give
him a Best Supporting Actor the guy
blows my mind for you guys one more um
this is the end the oh god there's one I
love that movie I laughed my ass comedy
the year away easily I think hands down
and there were some other things that I
laughed at very are but but I thought I
had very little expectation going into
that film and was I just literally
laughed my entire way the whole way
through
coming back give a stupid nomination I
everyone hates this film but I love
only God forgives and I love the
performance by Kristin Scott Thomas
which is just absolutely bananas and
banca where she plays Ryan Gosling's
mother in the film and I think she's
great but uh you know obviously no one
was going to nominate that well all
that's left is giving them out on Oscar
night who do you thinks gonna win
who is snubbed tell us in the comments
below the most awesome answer will send
you screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank this great panel Sam Huntington
check him out in being human it's on
sci-fi Mondays at 9:00 and he's also in
the upcoming Veronica Mars movie oh yeah
yeah man and Pat Healy check them out
coming up in cheap thrills draft day and
also uh you should have been nominated
as Best Supporting Actor and compliance
Wow last year them okay but saying uh
late it get your freaking great in that
Hagan um thanks for watching everybody
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter by
my best mainstream movie title that
sounds like a porno nominees are two
guns Pacific Rim delivery man jobs the
to-do list warm bodies Koch Mortal
Instruments City of Bones and the winner
is inside Lewin Davis